welcome everybody it's a lot of people
in this room is fantastic my name is
Damien I work on the dotnet team I'm
David so does David same team yep same
team and we're gonna look at application
Diagnostics today because despite
everyone's best efforts sometimes stuff
goes wrong in your app I don't make core
now that we're at version 3.1 we have
added some new features and some new
tools there's been some Visual Studio
enhancements etc etc which we're gonna
look at which will hopefully empower you
to find and diagnose issues with your
dotnet core apps running on all
platforms that's one of the things that
we've been focusing on as part of
the.net core 3x release so that's the
wrong machine so let's start right at
the beginning so when we talk about
Diagnostics what are the very core
primitives that we need to be aware of
as developers all this three there's
events there's metrics and those dumps
now some of you might be going where are
logs and traces and all these other sort
of terms that we've used over the years
well when you distill them all down
these are the three that we usually come
up with so logs and traces are just a
type of event we can debate whether it
you should call it logging or tracing or
anything else but for the purposes of
how we think about diagnostics and net
and how we build tools these are the
three things we think about
so our event is hey a thing happened and
he is usually a message and some other
data associated with that thing that
happened and if it's you know very lucky
you'll get a timestamp as well so here's
an example a request started here was
the path right and then he was some
other information maybe a query string
or some other information that was going
on there for a metric metrics are all
about numbers so if your a.net developer
and a Windows person for a long time
you'll be aware of things like
performance counters performance
counters were kind of built into the
platform and they were all dealt with
metrics how or numbers I should say in
dotnet core we've only just very
recently introduced a primitive that you
can use to omit counters or numbers and
so in this case an example would be
here's a number that represents the
current state of a thing that's where
what we're thinking about here so maybe
the CPU usage the number of things that
are in queued into some type of log of
work to be done like the thread pool
this is how long the last requests to go
process took etc etc so events are
things that happened and you get some
data metrics and numbers that represent
the state of something at the moment and
then lastly we have dumps everyone's
favorite past-time to go and look at a
huge block of memory use some esoteric
command-line tool or GUI and traverse
through your time travel back through to
find out what went wrong after it went
wrong okay there are a few different
types of dumps and we're gonna look at a
couple of them today and dumps are
probably sometimes one of the sort of
the best things that we have available
to us as developers but also one of the
most complicated and carve eiated things
you can use as well and we'll have a
look at that as well
that one over there thank you adding
value from useful I can't get in
confused cuz I put two keyboards you're
welcome very silly of me
all right so we've got our primitives
how we go about actually producing those
all right well we've got a logger so
ilogger is kind of our highest level
abstraction we introduced it as part of
a spinet call and as you can probably
tell from the name it's all about
emitting locks it supports structured
logging so that not only can you emit a
message you can provide us some
information about the thing that's going
on and you preserve that structure when
you egress the logs out to some type of
storage system so that you can search
for it later or correlate it with
something else we use a nice v-neck or
it's also used in any framework core and
it's really designed around our
dependency injection system it's
designed to work well with the
primitives and a spinet core so if
you're using signal are hubs or razor
pages or MVC controllers or middleware
it's very easy to get an instance of an
ilogger social workers write or workers
orgy RPC routine points or anything
that's built on the a spinet core
platform then we have something called
diagnostic source that was also
introduced when we were building a
spinet core how is it different well
diagnostic source is about being able to
give others an opportunity to get a live
object
when an event takes place what's an
example well when middleware is
processing a request or the server is
processing the request it may want to
fire an event saying hey a request is
starting and not only is a request
starting but here's the HTTP context and
then you can do something with that and
I'll wait for you because it's
synchronous it gets called inline and
then it can come back and then continue
on from that point on generally used by
diagnostic systems that you plug into
your applications like APM solutions so
you may use something like up inside app
insights or better if you're on trace or
New Relic or a lot more stackdriver
maybe any of these things that plug into
your application you add some code and
then they want to like get their
tendrils into the app to understand
what's going on diagnostic sauce is a
good primitive for doing that activity
so activity again was introduced at the
same time that we did diagnostic sauce
and it is basically a thing that says
something's about to start what's gonna
take place and then it's gonna stop all
right
the magic of activity is that it flows
over async calls in dotnet okay so it's
stored using the magic async local thing
in a speeder in sorry and net so you can
start an activity all types of stuff can
happen on that logical activity that you
created even if the hops over threads
you can make it off bound call to some
i/o and it can come back later and the
activity is still active and then you
can say stop and you'll get a time I see
a period of time that gets logged about
that activity which is kind of cool very
useful for distributed tracing which
we'll talk about we've also now finally
plumbed the CLR runtime events up
through from the native code into the
various ways that you can measure and
see diagnostic events in net and we'll
have a look at that in just a moment so
you can get things like how many GCS
have taken place how many threads are in
the thread pool etc etc things that the
CLR itself manages you can now get
access to in react to you can write code
that does stuff with that and then
finally we have at the very lowest level
there the thing that pretty much
everything else is built on
finally ultimately goes down to before
you do something else with it is a vent
sauce so a vent sauce is kind of in all
the dotnet so I think it's in all the
believers it's the thing that's
universal it is built-in and it produces
events and metrics there's a special
type of event sauce called an event
counter which ultimately goes down
through event source as well and that's
for counters and metrics and then
there's the base event sauce which emits
events you know we saw that in the first
slide you have events you need something
that emits events that's what event
sauce does so this is what I logo looks
like if we look at some examples of
these this in this case is a razor page
model as I said I log is really intended
and designed around being consumed in
your applications rather than perhaps
your libraries it's really intended for
use in your applications and so I take
in an ilogger of T where T is whatever
it is I'm logging about so in this case
it's my my index model and then in my
get request down there I get you know
the type of methods I'd expect on a
logging system I can log an information
message or I could log warning error etc
I've given it a string which represents
my message and then there's a token in
this case I've given the token a name
timestamp and then I can pass in the
value that gets associated with that
token and that's the structured part of
structured logging that you may have
heard before you know we didn't invent
this at all structured logging is
something that kind of came to be what
67 years ago or so I mean it's probably
around forever
I mean etw is a type of structured
logging but in terms of systems that it
predominantly you would say log this
message and then here's some data with
it people have been talking about
structured logging as a thing for a few
years now but this is an example of that
and the same one again I did it again
dinner
kostik sauce I need to log into this one
now because I just loved it there we go
it's a diagnostic sauce what does this
look like this is not as easy to use to
be fair because it's designed to be used
in a different way so this is a
middleware and so you can see the very
first thing at the top I've created an
instance of a diagnostic sauce that will
represent all the events that my app is
emitting
but and this one is static right you
create an instance of it usually I could
have put it as a singleton in my app or
something you should have probably
oh babe wouldn't have fit the fun okay
then I've got a middleware that I've
created that allows other things to plug
in and get told about things happening
in my requests pipeline there's actually
this actually I would just rip this off
this is in a spinet core and I just
renamed it and so here's my standard
middleware stuff that's gonna go off and
call the next middleware if necessary
and you can see down in the Evoque lines
down here this is what your diagnostics
or stuff will typically look like you
ask do then you want to enable me
because you don't want to trace or log
or omit you know you don't want to pay
the cost of this unless someone is
actually listening so am i enabled and
then if I am I go off and write out an
event from my diagnostic sauce and I
pass in the live object associated with
it in this case I'm giving people the
h-2b context and then they can do stuff
but I wait until this call is over
before I continue okay that's that's the
big thing about diagnostic source most
tracing systems or logging systems the
system logs an event and then someone
else gets that event at some point in
the future but the event happened in the
past okay you might write the event out
and eventually it makes it to a file or
it makes it to a database but there's no
chance for you to do anything and affect
it so this is quite powerful yep if you
live if you build yourself a diagnostic
listener which we'll look at in a minute
that can listen to these events you can
actually mutate this object your get a
copy of it you get the live object but
done but don't you shouldn't yeah the
side effects when logging a bad but it's
powerful and there may be cases of
people using this today to that effect
but we won't talk about that all right
event sauce this was the super low level
one that ultimately everything plums out
through this is kind of the default way
that events get out of dotnet core
applications today of course you can
write your own thing or bring in a third
party library that takes out another way
but this thing is built-in so how do I
use it I do I create a class that's
derived from the event source base class
I I've created an instance of that in
this case again it's static this is kind
of how this API is designed to be used
it's not designed with DI or testing or
anything in mind it's baked into the
framework so I create myself a property
essentially a read-only field called log
it's an instance of my events
and then I go ahead and add some methods
which represent each event
I want to omit so I've got a thing
happened and another thing happened I
can take data so again this is
structured you can pass in stuff here
and then they annotate those methods
with this event attribute where you must
have an ID so I've just got one and two
and usually it's just some number that
increases what level that event is and
then again I check if I'm enabled and if
I am I go ahead and call write event
with my event ID in my data okay also
the arguments don't support any type so
you can like port strings integers
doubles floats dictionaries but you
can't pass arbitrary how does this right
cuz I do to write them out exactly so
big caveat alright so what about
collecting these things there's some
examples of how we push them out but
what do I do to like read them right I'm
on the other side of the thing now so
well there's a whole bunch of API is
that they generally correlate with the
things that I've just talked about is an
event listener API to get things that
come from event source there's a
diagnostic listener API to get things
that come from diagnostic source there's
an event pipe API which I haven't talked
about yet because it's the next line and
the vent pipe API lets me connect to an
event pipe and an event pipe is a new
thing in dotnet core 3 that is always on
so when you create a dotnet core 3
process you start your application one
of the first things the runtime does is
open literally a named pipe on whether
on Windows or Linux and it's protected
with the same identity as the process
itself so you have to be running as the
same account as the process be able to
connect to it and then all events will
be emitted through there assuming
someone has turned them on ok so it does
nothing by default other than get open
and then it waits for someone to connect
to it and say hey can you please send me
these events ok it's effectively like
event tracing for Windows etw but it's
built into dotnet so it just works
everywhere and it's always on which is
kind of cool
Utd and then there is a set of CLI tools
that were released as part of DOC
McCrory that you can install we'll do
that in just a minute that you can use
to do all these types of things so you
can look at counters you can collect
traces and convert events in different
formats you can grab dumps if you need
to analyze memory you can grab a GC dump
which David I'll talk about the
difference between that
and then you may have heard of SOS
before which is the son of strikers what
it stood for it
it's the extensions for the window
windbg that you would use to analyze
manage memory while dotnet SOS is a
command-line tool that you can use to
basically enable SOS cross-platform
using whatever native debugging tools
you use on that platform and then dot
that symbol that you download symbols so
that once you have a memory dump you can
find out what source code at maps to ok
all right so what does eventlistener
look like well if I want to listen to
events from an event source i do this i
create an event listener i derive from
the event listener and then i write a
little bit of code that wires up the
fact that i want to listen to certain
events like a bigger deal ok that's
pretty easy that's a pretty easy thing
to understand diagnostic listener hacked
a little bit harder as we saw before the
code to emit diagnostic source is a
little bit strange and a little bit big
this is even weirder you know so they'll
be the live object that you're passed
when you're on the other side listening
to it you don't know the type it's not
type safe you just get given an object
and then you have to know what type it
is
caster to that in order to use it so in
this case i think i'd say in 3hp context
yet down here and so right down here and
my on next i'm switching on the key and
if the key was this is this is the event
name then i go ahead and i just cast the
value so a should be context i come to
new subscribers alright and so you also
know that this class here my Annelle
analysis middleware event observer is
implementing two different interfaces
that are both i observer of t one of
them represents the fact that i want to
listen to that diagnostic sauce and then
the other one represents the fact that i
want to listen to particular events from
that diagnostic source that there's kind
of two stages of subscribing to things
from diagnostic sauce i don't know why
do you know why i know it sees in the
yeah i mean so the for the first level
is in imagine you want listen on HTTP
client and it's connect or you would
subscribe and then do an if check to see
if the name with its net korish be
client okay so you can then subscribe to
individual like sources themselves so
that's this one here the first level
once you find that then for each source
you can
turn on individual events for a source
so it makes sense it's just really hard
to to use alright I mean you could make
these separate classes that's right in
this case it's just the same class so
things like app insights and open start
racing like support these patterns right
okay and then the event pipe API this is
the from a different process I can
connect to the diagnostic server or the
event pipe of another dotnet process and
there's an API that shipped that lets
you do that
it's this is an example of doing so this
one prints out all the runtime GC events
from another process which is kind of
cool so you can kind of get the sense of
how powerful this is in terms of being
able to create systems that monitor
dotnet core applications and then do
something with the events that come out
of there one of the things I haven't
mentioned is a vent pipe is actually not
just a pipe for getting data it actually
accepts commands so once the pipe is
established I can send commands to kind
of the diagnostic server running in
the.net core app which is just there by
default again and then ask it to do
things all right it supports eventing in
both directions which is pretty cool so
I also mentioned some CLI tools let's go
and show a example of that I'm not going
to close your terminal don't okay a new
one so the CLI tools that we've released
our new and you install them separately
from the dotnet core STK Oh they've got
Nico runtime by a dotnet
global tools so how do I get those well
I can type dotnet tool not - no - g4
global and then I type in the name so we
had dotnet trace and we have dotnet
counters I'm pretty sure you've already
got them installed just do i oh okay so
I'm assuming you've got the right
version I could try and update it but
I'll just just leave it at this rate so
if I type dot net counters now that I've
got it installed okay so it says
required commandments are provided but
you can see what's what I have available
to me so it says PS here I can list the
dotnet processors on this machine that I
could attach to to look at counters so
if I type dotnet counters may actually
pass PS as the command and says there's
only one net process
anyone want to guess which one it is
that's right it's this one that I just
wrote it's my just efficient but I mean
there it lists itself which isn't
particularly useful so let's create
another one I want that's the vs let's
try it it's a preview that'll do that's
fine that'll work it's dog food I'm just
gonna create a brand new a spinet core
application we'll call it that
417 I want to see it wrapped are all
right and I'll just run this is just a
standard web application so I know I
want to I just want to get another
process going it's going it's going
alright so there's my opponent we
couldn't log you in right now
oh it's the last part all right so let's
run that again and see what we have
oh look I've got more processors so now
I have another dotnet there no whoa
what's that I don't know hmm anyway this
is the one I'm interested is Express is
a process that is hosting net core
because in a snake or three we default
to in process hosting when you're using
I yes so in theory I should be able to
just like attach to that right so how do
I do that I go doc net count is if
there's a monitor that looks good
because I want to see them and I have to
pass it appeared which is - P and in
this case it's one eight three one two
oh okay waiting finish your payload no
no I got some stuff showing on my screen
all right so I'm gonna pin this to the
let book that's not the left that's the
top corner that's that that's that was
it I'm not gonna close it all right so I
now I need to generate some load the f5
key is a perfectly good tool for doing
that
and so I didn't scroll look I'm not
seeing everything all right so up here
we've got CPU counters right this isn't
really very much I probably need to show
some different counters to see something
useful here no I think in rating much
load you think what I have a theory
what's this theory I think the tool is
rendering Li improperly say I think you
have to keep the console at the same
size no no I'm not shrink it does that
work well I think I just
generating enough load to show anything
so what I want to do is add some other
counters here I need to add only F no
connotation 8 core counters now I can't
seem to get control C to work on your
laptop just don't close it I'll open
another one in this duct it just needs
to be stuck that's the right key right
then you brick it I didn't do anything
don't let p.m. touch a computer ran
ahead
counters we're looking at my processes
all right so that's still there it's all
good good three three one two wait
there's more
well this one's stopped that's so that
one's stuck so it's still that we'll
just close that one that's fine all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right
preparation dotnet counters counters we
want to monitor and I need to go to one
eight three one two and I need to pass
providers provide two dashes providers
and I need to put in Microsoft Connect
or hosting it's a lot of stuff hosting
hosting coming space system runtime
right all right so I've just passed in
say not just the default count as I want
to listen to some other stuff so now
we've got two categories a snick or
hosting counters and system dot runtime
I'm allocating memory where than what
I'm doing you think that's great all
right so if I go back to my I'm just
gonna leave it I'm not gonna touch the
console I can make it Angry
and now if I do this nothing oh look
total requests without look at that so
now I can see live counters going off in
my browser because I've got monitors so
great if he is plan Mon ever you this
isn't news to you but this is new for
dotnet core and it works across platform
I could also run collect instead of
monitor here and I would get all this in
from
out in a file so then I could use that
later on for something email I see if
control C works this time oh look it is
there fine it's all good all right what
else can we do we had dotnet trace was
the other one right that we talked about
so don't no trace let me try and collect
a profile of some sort so I'll do net
trace I need to get my process ID again
don't I so what was it one eight three
one two dotnet trace collect four - P of
one eight three losses one two all right
so it's collecting a trace right now let
me go generate some load how fast can I
hit a phone all right then I go back and
says hit Enter which we know works so
well on your laptop
all right so choice complaint what did
that give me a lot of files in this I
shouldn't have done this in you User
Profile [ __ ] right there this is the
farm after I got a trace dotnet trace
file down here you should be the Dino
alright so delete trace down manually
window to the barn all windows Oh LS
does that make you feel better
alright so I got this trace net trace
file I could have specified a file name
this is just the default
okay so what can I do with that so I've
got this new trace file well I know that
I can drag that individual studio is
everyone who's worth anything does all
their DevOps with GUI tools right that's
what we do all right so he's my Explorer
over here oh my god this profile folder
meant net trace was it trace terrific
there it is alright so I go over the
movi s and then you've got snap thing he
turned on and I will click and drag that
over here and I wait
look at that and now it opens up the
virtual studio CPU a profiling view with
the net trace information whole bunch of
stuff going on so it's the count of
events as limited to me anyway it's a
whole bunch of information if you've
used these tools before this is pretty
much the standard profiling visualizer
individual studio but I've used this new
file format
I could have created that file on a
Linux machine or a Mac and then brought
it over here and looked at this way
instead are there any other tools that
can look at this perfume I don't know
how to use presses press the mode so
dotnet and dotnet trace all right very
cool all right back to here I'll let you
take everything just to just to cool all
right let's start by showing some actual
scenario so okay extreme interestings
anyone here doing micro services more
than one service more than one
application yeah no yeah okay sure
yes I believe you in a minute Cora 3.0
will be added support for distributed
tracing had an in Coast because it kind
of got to kind of add it and a kind of
stuff to make it work well and to end
but if all there's no viewer for
distributed traces so you have to have a
software tool like Yaeger or Zipkin or
up insights to actually get the antenna
experience so by default what we did in
a net core is it's been a core by
default they will create an activity
which has an ID and then every time an
Alabang HP client calls made to any
back-end server it'll embed a new ID
that is kind of a hierarchy of IDs that
gets passed the other server then a
smoker will read ID on the incoming
request so you get a beautiful
end-to-end trace question ID but to a
Tory they make h-2b calls between them
and you know effectively they will share
ID ID the phonological requests between
them so that you can correlate yeah
there's a new standard that was invented
by a couple of companies like Google and
Microsoft and dynaTrace Uralic called
the w3c trace context
historically people have been there
oh I thought you said your wife I was
working mr. ed it was okay
historically people have invented places
to put these headers to correlate
information and the whole goal is could
we agree on the header name so we got 10
companies to get to figure out what the
name should be for the header but it it
took it took two years but then we have
a draft that suspect Grayson
Microsoft Google obtained a trace Google
again literally I'm Microsoft two months
ago oh really you so it's brand new an
asp net core and Donette core as a whole
and we agree on a header called trace
context I think it's called traits
context but nobody agree right so all
good okay so let me show an example of
this working
steamin didn't kill my whole good good
so I have two applications of front end
and the back end both a spinette core
they mentioned activities in in its
first slides activity is kind of two
things
it is both represents a span of time so
you can start and stop one and it also
stores the IDS across the AC local
boundary okay so when you start activity
it generates an ID based on whatever
scheme we want to invent so there's two
schemes
there's default old-school we made up
our own thing and then this thing came
out I'll be really okay that seems to be
D officially to do it so we we actually
added support not a core three for this
new spec which I hope doesn't die
because then that would make our thing
obsolete so activity by default I can
say I want my ID format to be w3c it's
not on by default in three row because
we didn't want to break people going
from 2d to trio see my team had that's
not all by default yes so by default
there's a format called all-purpose
hierarchical and there's unknown which
is Li I'm not sure you did
it's pretty funny actually
how is that useful what's befallen you
need other just in case someone messed
up alright so by default you get the
inherit hierarchical ID and this is an
ID that was kind of invented from
internal Microsoft we have we copied a
form from internal that we made public
and that is a real kind of a real thing
so we made some work for it if you had a
2 - app deployed and updated 3 oh we
didn't want to break you by making the
default ID be the new format so by
default if you if your first application
instance at the d3c trace context
compatible ID we will we will use that
as the base for other IDs right if you
send the OID that becomes the base I see
so it's kind of smart it kind of says if
you sent me the new ID now that's what
you get
yeah person does that request or it does
it pro request request yep ok so here's
a basic application using a spinette
core I set the defy you to the w3c and
then I turned on Sarah log a very
popular logging library and Donna is it
on you Sarah log wow that's just Gator
bar looks great
Sarah log there's a there's also a a
blogging system called SEC seep SEC SEC
SEC will you call it seek seek seek I
don't believe you seek it's a super nice
blogging system I have it installed I'm
gonna just pretend I didn't do this
before so let me delete all the logs ha
ha but basically is a system let's see
let's look at logs in a structured way
clear clear clear
alright empty and I have that word up in
my friend and application the front-end
all it does is it creates name should be
client once and then hard cause the
backend URL and then calls the backend
and gets a string and then race to the
response so very basic right on the
backend what it does is the same thing
as it has an endpoint called back-end B
and it does some intensive IO work
and then it reply is hella NDC back-end
to get this beautiful view that we have
in our slide it's like beautiful we call
Gantt chart waterfall it's a waterfall
view of like here's magnet request
here's what was a part of it and then it
keeps going down to get that you need a
tool like Zipkin so I have the cam
running in a container
defconn's is a open source software you
can run on your whatever machines yeah
but it also refracting sites so I have
wired up in my application open
telemetry and open flama tree is anyone
here heard about open tracing open
tracing was a thing that some person
made a long time ago and they basically
invented this whole just distributed
systems distributed tracing ID leading
scheme and that was super cool but then
it didn't work for other people so then
open telemetry was supposed to be an
effort to fix all the previous things
that were kind of one-offs to actually
think about ant and for doing metrics
tracing logging so it's kind of a spec
so if you look if you search for open
telemetry and there were three of them
there is open tracing open stance system
nodes opening lemon tree this is this is
this is the last one good one they
figured it out this is the last one so
if you go onto this thing it suspect
they have clients for every language
every every platform there's a joint
effort between companies so Microsoft is
investing in it so as Google so is
notorious and etc there is a github so
JavaScript Python Ruby go Java C sharp C
sharp metrics and tracing for each one
we're good the dots are super late
because it's very early still asleep
yeah so Wow that's the quickest
QuickStart I've ever seen
so yeah it it's not all there yet it's
still in high churn yeah we're working
with the team actually to build the API
make it be very nice but on that thing
isn't like version one yet it's still
happening zero points based on something
else before okay but because it's based
on what was it based on w3c of the trace
context that is used it's used is used
in this yep but you can wire it up today
yeah
they're trying to be basically the
one-stop shop for metric logging - let
me treat attributed tracing for all
things so there's a spec for for a
protocol to do remote logging remote
metrics remote tracing and they're
trying to basically make it and they'll
be all for all languages which always
goes well start here that's just how I
feel about it so I have wired up Zipkin
so I'd open telemetry there's a packet
it show the package the package is
called open tell feel like hosting this
where to the are generic host as
extension of this word for the ASP micro
a container and I added an exporter
called zip in so the way it works is you
create we create activities in the
framework open Flemmi tree can listen to
those events using a listener and then
they create their internal their
internal representation of a hierarchy
of the actual call tree this is all
plugged in using those primitives we
learned about write events so yep
exactly
and then those events go through an
exporter I'm just export for different
Mac and there's one for app insights
there's one for Zipkin Jaeger and other
systems so you add an exporter you add
collectors for different dependencies
exponet core is one one is h-2b client
why is the address decadence all right
right those all email activities and
events for not just sources okay and so
I said I want to use it pin I just gonna
figured out localhost blah EPA spines
not important my service name is
front-end and then I added the a spec or
request collector
I'm the dependencies I think his address
DK and I should be quiet okay right it
means dependency from the point of view
of your app is
Paul - a dependency right and so
built-in to.net core HP client will just
automatically stamp an activity onto the
request that goes out bound okay so if I
run this application they should
function
okay did this not work let's hear that 5
this is for a full oh that's fine it's
ok so this is the front end hidden the
back end on /b right and if I go to the
second UI which is localhost my for for
one stare there the services and there
are the actual calls where news first
here this is the one three spends wait
what huh where is the front end isn't
know what I want it's fun and that's not
nothing there oh don't look too
correlated huh the picture is good it
did say alpha on it to be fair this
absolutely works 100% okay sort of level
super high back end failed but if I go
to be easy to work right yes this is
your back in two seconds and that's the
front end calling the back end okay
there we go
so as I was saying opportunity here is
the overall front end request this is
the album call from the front end to the
back end this is a should be client a
ball request and this is the back end of
work happening itself so if I'm to think
about this space and everything we just
said the first horizontal line is a
speed net cord tracking the fact that it
got a request from the browser yep the
second line is HTTP client saying I'm
about to make connect best of all that's
all I'm still in the first app at this
rate and then the third horizontal line
is my back-end app is running a spinet
course saying I got a request
and they're all joined together because
magic magic well because of all the
things that right so they all have the
same trace idea if I look at this
information is showing the incoming
requests it's showing the user agent the
URL hit on the front end and it has show
IDs here is the overall trace for that
entire spine okay it's like it's like
the logical operation yeah this is the
orbital operation right each span is an
operation so span is one of those calls
one of those long ones length and the
trace is the overall expression right
got it
if I look at this B it should have the
same trace idea but different spend on a
parent and the parent was in the
parentage of previous spend got it right
so but that we can build a hierarchy of
children but a parent relationship of
all the trace IDs and we can build the
entire tree in Chilean in ICU I ask a
question the question was if my front
end has to call multiple back-end in
parallel will it create like multiple
IDs to track the spans right yes yes yes
if you would have visualized them here
you would see multiple horizontal lines
with the same starting point rocket
right and then finishing at different
times and then coming together yep is it
linden browser the browser view it's a
little bit like you know the chrome
network do you look memory o-6 requests
in parallel and then yeah exactly like
that so that's cool now I can see it
show me all logs for this tricity let's
see if this works
so we can imagine the scenario maybe a
front-end user got an error page and on
that error page you print an ID and say
you can call support or start chat now
and then the the support person says
well do you have a trace ID or an error
ID and they say yes they give it to them
and they put it in their back-end system
like this and then look at that you get
all the stuff associated with it from
every hot right sweaty fought SPI Korra
will stamp the treat ID into every
single log during the request so I can
filter and seek to say give me all log
of that habit resetti and since both are
logging their logs to the same I seek I
can see the logs across both things
super nice very cool can i navigate in
seek from that waterfall you showed me
to the logs corresponding to each span
they have like a nice click around thing
there are two different tools now all
one was ippon and one was this okay is
it one tool like happiness never happy
never happier okay sorry I mean that's
fine I'm a PM you can make it simple for
me every day okay
all right moving up to generation let's
let's look at some other stuff all right
what do we have next app is leaking
memory
this never happens okay has anyone had a
leak in production I don't make me
relapse this okay awesome awesome
awesome so a wolf I gonna do here I had
a thing I had a set of script oh there's
a script yes where though never leaked
all right
I have this application that I wrote a
long time ago so I have a repository on
github just shameless plug
ohohoho that basically has all the
things you should never do with the
internet core right and it had it I mean
the danger is people may copy the code
think he has leaked legitimate there's a
there's a there's a report here that
basically has a bad code and it says bad
in the name so I'm hoping people are
like oh says by should copy it for
example it has things like basic voice
which is you should never do ever ever
ever ever crashing a process memory
leaks so for this demo I actually added
a couple more scenarios so I have no
intended for now a controller that leaks
memory but yeah excellent
so what it does is it has a static
concurrent action Eric Astra's thread
safe and whenever you ask for an ID to
the leak endpoint it will give you an ID
I was cashed that's five that five makes
five makes yeah okay all right so this
seems good right it seems fine what if
you can't figure what the actual problem
is right so you didn't see the killer
because it was because I wrote it I need
to put it okay
so let me run the application have it
running it ready on this then let me use
I have a tool called Bombardier that
I've been using for a while is red dingo
tools
Roger enough you know you have to just
like one-up me but absolutely it
generates more like this I was pathetic
I can hit that five for you
oh the first thing I wanna do is
actually run done it counters on that up
do you want to see it right the net
counters I should put this over here
oh no delicately it's not about work oh
nice
okay client/server if it sounds if it
looks crazy let me know as I'm trying to
leave make sure it's not crazy fun
encounters PS scenarios I really wanted
action name yeah yeah yeah monitor will
get a fix P 2 0 3 3 2 providers I'd like
to have completion for this bit that
would be good I'm sure you all right no
okay alright looks good looks good
Happy's running all good and then I can
use some code that I wrote before and we
heard in the PowerShell so go from 0 to
30 and hit this just says 0 to 30 for
each create random object and then hit
that point with the random ID okay use
bum ba da I can't because I need to I
need to be different every single day
okay
this works this is like fast for this
for this one yeah
okay all right
it arrived and no the counters should
give us some information
whoa holy whoa look at that
so basically big clue right it's merely
okay hmm that's weird
what next then you take your other tool
dotnet let's do a dump first net dump
collect what's the pong stupid' reverse
sir she's amazing
Oh baby that counters there it is
darn it don't collect back get rid of
all this 23 2 2 3 2 2 that's amazing
that's not running that's the wrong what
is the processing hey what just list
them again oh they go twenty three three
three okay all right so I have a full
dump for the process what's a mini dump
it says mini dump it just has less stuff
than what than the folder you just said
okay love Cory right Lester I did it
user profile okay I just whatever don't
what's the color oh there it is
yeah so I should be able to put this
into yes drag into here I think this
only works on via enterprise someone
told me last talk hold on pause pause
it's fine it's fine okay alright so here
is the dump load into those two you and
I can see that there's a ton of
concurrent action area nodes here so
yeah that's about right not much
breathing with full dose you get the
full object graph you get the full
memory so as a result they're very big
even those mini I believe it is still
like huge enormous you keep saying full
dump is this a unique number a full dump
I mean it literally said mini done right
hang a mini up sorry okay full dump
would be bigger than this yes this was
like so this tries to only get the GC
heap okay this is hitman the manage
memory okay because it doesn't mean much
I still 500 miles for my super small
process okay so card I'm offended so my
code um with a dump
yes format with any dump like this okay
the dump is platform dependent so I
can't get it on the next copy to witness
I mean that work it is tightly
to a platform that's super is it hard to
be in a container have a memory leak
capture a dump put it somewhere else and
then look at it off box you have to have
the exact same architecture so business
you need to have the same kernel see if
you're running an alpine container if
you look at don't we have to get an
alpine container to actually run this to
look at the actual studio for alpine
last time I touch in that case if I'm
running on Linux yep used to point to
Linux
today don't they call hey lots of folks
so this is good for Windows the yes what
do I do for Linux don't have bugs so you
heard it here folks dotnet car is
cross-platform as long as you don't have
buddy there's a there's a new tool we
wrote like I want to say it a month ago
yes I think it's be shipped called it GC
dotnet GC don't do you see them this
this has been around in a while in
perfume as a format the only perfect
understood and now it's become a generic
format okay so as you see dump is a very
very very different kind of dump even
though it's called it dump must obtain
hold on let me okay this time there's
something over to 0 3 3 2 right don't
need it don't need you guys so here I
made a change dump did you see dump and
I got the same same command okay
it is tiny you could it's a different
look that thing got GC dump file
beautiful okay where is it
hey oh wow okay 1k so then how do I use
it
yeah okay do you need to use it so I
don't want to see the old buggy cut
where I knew okay in VF I have no idea
what version stacking point something
point something you drag in this file
and now it should give you the same view
but for whoa okay and does that have to
be enterprise it was at any version any
version whoa any version you
[Laughter]
so with UC dumps the only thing you get
it stores tight names okay
counts sizes okay and you you do get
links between opposite in the graph
cannot see fields you don't get feel so
you can't do you can do like show me the
value of the entry of the string so it's
not for like full-on advance to buggy
marries we wonder if I find the request
object and then navigate to something
that it links to and then look at the
private field on that object to figure
something out right doesn't need all the
memory for that right but if you just
want to get counts out in summaries and
them yeah DC roots and stuff let me know
it's a tiny file to and you said I could
have I could have captured that on Linux
yep and then I opened it in vs that's
right okay Wow let's go what else can I
open it in anything else
perfect that's Windows you oh okay every
time is half perfect instead of it this
tool is horrible but late is really good
for it's really it's really powerful but
I don't not not great for you not great
you and stuff so it does support you see
dumps too and it does show something in
excel style tables I guess so ref to ref
from is a flame graph so like super
pretty sure what is he showing guys this
is not useful okay there it is
computation areas the issue I mean I can
see yeah see that the big number is what
I did right here good all right perfect
so there's there's the leak cool all
right so where were we
wait hold on I miss one more thing I
missed the allocation profiler okay let
me show one more thing if you're in a
place where you can actually run in your
dev cycle to test memory we shipped a
brand new memory profiler let me close
things first that's fine that's fine
that's fine
okay so in the alt f2 tools so we call
them nope that's not that's not alt
that's not all we all have two tools I
think I believe you get there from doing
analyze no no actually don't
fools together from week you use the
search hit alt f2 and we have a few news
an envious that we've been working on so
there's a new a brand new allocation
profiler there's a database tool to see
database queries there's memory usage or
CPU usage and any event viewer and
that's showed up in your in your profile
or you show the events oh and they were
events that yes right okay I believe
it's still here actually so there anyway
doesn't matter so let me start the
project by doing that question is is
this in old yes yes yeah I think this
one is absolutely I'm pretty sure yes
pretty sure pretty I'm pretty sure
pretty pretty sure pretty sure that we
asked them to put it in all of them yes
if it's not pretty sure it is leaked all
the memory leak all the memory and then
stop collection we are working on the
performance please forgive me it's the
only thing that's wrong right now you
know it's gonna work
it's crunching numbers and Lee trying to
give you a pretty graph that's the
million dollar question
we're obviously not using this tool man
myself cuz if we were it would be faster
already bad I was alright shut up man
we iconoclast we I was so happy I'd like
Hans I call it okay so you can see
allocations and strings are crazy and
you can click on the actual type over
here and then it shows me stacks so I
can see where it happened and I'm like
ham from the leek controller because it
has the lowest allocate the most does it
the most the most right cool so there
you go excellent allocation profile GC
dump
mini dump filled up yeah yeah we didn't
do a full dump at all right now
you can't take a full dump you can no
you can't you can't but there are other
tools you can take full dumps yes
there's a mean task manager or a proper
or on Linux called Dom core dump okay
mm-hmm and why would you want to do that
over a mini dump my seed up all the
memory if you're like olden they native
memory management all the memory all the
password people have in there a people
crypto key cookie not even kidding I
mean okay all right so app is leaked
what about this one a sink oh I remember
here last year talking about a sink okay
yeah all right so what have we done it's
been a year what have you done okay
it's too much pressure because there was
so much stuff we told people not to do
last year and now I want to know if they
still don't do that stuff okay don't do
that stuff well that hope that hasn't
changed but if you do okay
we added actually so first thing as we
added a few counters to make async
debugging easier so I want to show my
mega app has an endpoint and alright
they're all terrible but this one let's
see a sink off perching yes so there's
bad bad but bad blocking one to like 15
okay let's run this application and then
use Bombardier it's a hit a sink one but
I also want to run counters your app not
running are you running yep okay six 500
okay okay I want you to run on this one
okay I'm bored you're here running for a
minute
hitting a sink and point doing sink over
a sink so there's some new clues you can
use to figure out if you're doing really
bad things we added a thread pool of
thread account so that's not good Wow
you have 750 cores in your surface
laptop mmm so high thread count low CPU
so just at a glance you can tell about
the starvation right so we're gonna have
more tools to figure out to scan cars
and give you and give you hints as to
what may be happening right any more any
more hints cue a few length is one hours
to this interesting the request count is
like going extremely slowly RPS is one
so you used all those clues to figure
out hey that it's probably a bad sign
right if you're blocking though we do
have to get tools already so if you're
envious and I attach to this process all
right
what you got just my code turned on I
thought gosh because of the other demo
oh okay it's not is a release build and
you're on release that's intentional I
know I'm just translating what it said
when it said you were using a release
build and you have just my code 10 but
what did the thing want pause with you
bugger
alright halt it debug Windows parallel
stacks this works already alright hmm
maybe I have too many stacks your app is
so broken maybe for a minute oh wait app
mmm the client died horribly Wow
did die so if you have seen the prowl
stats view oh wait hello is there
parallel stacks view the parallel stalks
view the parallel stacks view if you've
seen this view is super cool super
useful it gives you pretty pictures of
stacks and we improved it in the newest
BS by having a thing called parallel
tasks so give you the same kind of you
prefer tasks so normally if you have
stuck stuck tasks stuck tasks in the
process it's really hard to see them you
don't have any stocks there's no threads
you can't look at anything
when you say stuck you mean that they
there's nothing running right ain't no
wait stay there in a white state sorry
not on a thread right and so you can't
see them unless you previously you would
have to take a like a mini dump right
that's right then you would have to like
find all the instances of them and then
you know figure it out from sort of
first primitives but now let me yeah do
it there maybe maybe 800 threads was too
many they killed it so instead let me
use all my super pre-canned dumps like I
just take those sorry collect those all
the time and I have one hair
that was GG via text oh that was even
intentional where I have a dump there we
go and then I can debug it and then I
can use parallel stacks to see that
there's nothing there there's a wait for
main and this is the default view the
existing of this is parallel stacks red
threads okay so there's threads right
here but then to the new parallel tasks
tasks whoo okay this view shows you
logical stacks so there's nothing like
blocking a thread but their actual
logical calls that are waiting in state
machines all right so all just all the
Steamies in memory are just hanging out
there waiting for things to resume and
now you have a view that kind of shows a
logical call stack based on what's
waiting on who and it's grouped them by
what's on the stack so that's great or
over there and each one of those and two
of that one and okay yeah so for example
there's two things here waiting for it
actively okay right so typically if
you've introduced a bug because you did
something bad and async you'll do this
and then you'll see like one group will
have 4,000 things like waiting with the
same stack because you accidentally
introduced it in one part of your
application right right so slow slow it
should be client calls for example or
good way to see it in this thing these
tools okay top delays that are there
randomly etc okay the question is I in
this state is the information for the
correlated activity in the dump the
answer is yes it has to be in the memory
and but you'd have to traverse it and
find it's not yeah it's not sure here we
don't have that view yet but we're
thinking about what it means have a
request based like view right back to
the slides because we are out of time
all right so there's a couple other
things obviously if the app is crashing
the one thing that you can do is quite
common today is you would want to be
able to say when the app crashes please
collect a dump all right and so there is
an environment variable you can set in
dotnet core that when the app crashes
just before it exits the host will
actually collect a mini dumb yep a mini
dump for you and then that's platform
dependent you'll have to if you're on
Linux you'll have to use ll TB TB to do
native debugging and then you can
SOS using.net SOS and their symbols then
you can do that debugging on the same
platform so as usual if you've got any
questions thank you for coming if you've
got any questions reach out to us on
Twitter this is still an evolving space
for dotnet core we have shown you a lot
of stuff that is somewhat bleeding-edge
it's just been released since 300 and 31
and is still being worked on and so we
would love to get your feedback there is
documentation and all this stuff already
so please do try it out give us feedback
and we will hopefully improve these
tools for you over the next year so
thanks for coming
[Applause]